histamina pós covid e ativação de mastos
tem cura ou apenas tratamento bem a
estamina pós-covid e a ativação de
mastos São condições que podem surgir em
alguns indivíduos que tiveram infecção e
elas estão relacionadas a uma Resposta
imune anormal e a liberação excessiva de
histamina bem recapitulando sobre a
histamina é um neurotransmissor e também
um mediador químico ele tá envolvido em
várias funções do corpo Inclusive a
regulação do Sono da digestão e da
resposta alérgica os mastos são a
principal célula do sistema de defesa
imune que libera histamina em resposta
vários estímulos como é o caso de
alergias infecções ou pessoas que têm
intolerância a estamina a condição de
estamina pós covid é ativação de mastos
não tem uma cura definitiva no sentido
tradicional mas tem tratamentos e
abordagens que pode ajudar a gerenciar
os sintomas e melhorar a qualidade de
vida e o tratamento geralmente envolve
medicamentos que reduzem a ação de
stamina ou bloqueiam os efeitos is pode
incluir antistamínico
que bloqueiam os receptores de istamina
que são os antialérgicos aliviando
sintomas como coceira vermelhidão e
congestão você tem também os
estabilizadores de mastócitos o mais
conhecido é o cromoglicato de sódio que
podem impedir a liberação de stamina
pelos mastócitos e temos também os
antagonistas dos receptores de
leucotrienos que é o caso do
montelucaste você pode usar uma
combinação de desses três aí ou um
desses três e tem também os inibidores
de receptores H2 que são medicamentos
que foram classicamente utilizados para
reduzir a produção de ácido do estômago
eram os remédios mais utilizados antes
dos prazois para gastrite esses remédios
podem ajudar a controlar a liberação de
estamina e tem as abordagens
integrativas existem abordagens naturais
que podem ser bastante úteis então fazer
uma dieta baixa em estamina ou uma dieta
Low f map cortando aqueles alimentos
mais problemáticos como queijo vinho
alguns peixes isso pode ajudar a reduzir
os níveis de histamina no corpo e os
suplementos que eu já comentei numa
outra resposta a Vitamina C com que
cetina a Ortiga de oica são substâncias
naturais que estabilizam os mastócitos e
também pode reduzir a liberação de
histamina e tem um estilo de vida
saudável incluindo uma dieta equilibrada
exercícios regulares gerenciamento do
estresse isso tudo pode ajudar reduzir a
ativação de mastócitos e liberação de
stamina então resumindo embora não haja
uma cura definitiva para estamina pós
covid ativação de mastócitos nós podemos
ter essa combinação de estilo de vida
tratamentos medicamentosos e abordagens
integrativas pode ajudar bastante a
melhorar a qualidade de vida gerenciar
esses sintomas de uma maneira muito
equilibrada